it is a gang of white girls getting it
yo wassup team Coco is your man Deon
Cole and these are some of my favorite
YouTube videos The Breakfast Club this
first video is this guy that was on The
Breakfast Club we got a special guest in
the building
well I'd watch interviews on The
Breakfast Club and this one guy
it was just powerful and they inspired
me that's right you see them on blackish
every week my man d'arco house me I
always liked that show and finally I had
the opportunity to go in there Charlie
cago is having a moment between you and
little Ralph it was fantastic working
with those guys shout out to the
Breakfast Club and everything they don't
yeah yeah dude by me like 50 bucks
actually was watching Eddie Murphy
delirious and my boy was like I bet you
can do that this next video that I love
is this song by Justin Bieber called
sorry is a gang of white girls getting
it in get it in in means dancing they
ass off they made black women from
Jamaica look sad but he did that on
purpose I think he and putting a black
girl's in there cuz he want to show now
my race he did it too well you don't
adjust you proved your point
[Music]
this next video is special to me because
when conan got over the TV yes he tried
to get as many viewers as possible and i
told him i was gonna help him out CBS
has done a great job for advertisement
you know but they didn't make no black
commercials for you yeah commercial for
white people like they might have a Thai
commercial me a white family and they
clean their clothes and everybody's
happy but then sometimes black
commercial be like go get your tie tie
tie cleaning clothes cleaning clothes
I made this commercial for calling it
and it blew up and it is one of my
favorite bits that I wrote on the show
so yes this next video is one of my
favorites I love watching animals attack
animals don't write me let us Peter
none of you are but I do I like to see
how they go in for dinner and one animal
that is overlooked is Eagles Eagles
awesome and fishes mother you should see
what they do watch this clip
and this last video is one of my
favorites when a black girl gets jumped
by three white girls and one black girl
and she's walking her dog what do you
use as a weapon your damn dog she picked
the dog up and beat they ass with the
dog and the dog looked pretty cool with
it like they rehearsed this before
didn't be slow the video down look at
the dog he's looking at highlight we got
him [ __ ] it's really cool check it out
I'm Deon Cole and thanks for watching my
favorite YouTube videos mr. Deon Cole
[Applause]
[Music]